ciao bella è la ciclabile indoor 30
metri di ciclabile in
trenta metri di ciclabile
al coperto ne ho una anche in casa un
metro e mezzo dal bagno alla camera da
letto un giorno ve la presento
allora la paura partiamo da qui la paura
è una brutta bestia soprattutto quando è
paura per l'incolumità l'incolumità
nostra e dei nostri
familiari
lo sapete che la paura di essere
investiti e la prima ragione per cui la
gente non va in bicicletta la seconda
ragione è paura di subire il furto della
bicicletta come vedete la paura
condiziona gran parte della mobilità
delle nostre città
ma
è davvero importante chiedersi
quali sono le ragioni per cui la
bicicletta non viene usata non è forse
più importante chiedersi perché viene
usata a bologna ad esempio il 10 per
cento degli spostamenti quotidiani
sono fatte in bicicletta c'è un mucchio
di gente che va in bicicletta chiedersi
perché queste persone utilizzano la
bicicletta probabilmente ci aiuta un
pochettino di più non trovate
allora provate a pensare perché tutta
questa gente va in bicicletta
lo so state pensando
a tutta una serie di buone motivazioni
di carattere nazionale del tipo produco
endorfine si diceva prima con il
movimento oppure
risparmio soldi oppure mi tengo in forma
oppure ancora salvo il pianeta sono
tutte motivazioni
interessanti hanno un vizio però un
problema sono tutte motivazioni
razionali invece la paura colpisce qua
le motivazioni razionali con la paura
non hanno chance perché la paura e
pensiero veloce
la razionalità invece è pensiero lento
noi dobbiamo provare a trovare
ed è quello che sosterrò oggi una
emozione una passione che possa
controbilanciare la paura
vi racconto una storia una storia che è
accaduta mia caduta 15 anni fa
era il 23 gennaio del 2000 deciso di
fare un buon giro in bicicletta di
quelli tosti di quegli epici 120 km da
bologna al mare facendo però strade
secondarie cavedagni
strade bianche e argini del fiume reno
non sono preparato a fare questo
percorso non off non ho abbastanza
chilometri nelle gambe però voglio farlo
sono
sono pronto con una bicicletta nuova che
però non lo domata che questo è un altro
problema parto parto dopo quindici
chilometri comincia a nevicare
allora voi provate ad immaginare non
tanto la neve perché la neve se sei
vestito bene non è un problema se hai un
equipaggiamento adeguato ricordate
quella roba da boy scout che diceva non
esiste buono cattivo tempo ma soltanto
equipaggiamento adeguato bene se tu sei
coperto bene la neve non è un problema
il problema c'è quando la neve copre
ogni ogni percorso e quindi non vi è di
più le buche 15 salti dentro quindi
tutto il percorso diventa più faticoso
bene
il percorso parte in salita dopo 50 km
sono un po stanchino come avrebbe detto
forrest gump e allora mi metto in scia
come si fa di chi va meglio di te per
prendergli la scia che cosa succede che
lentamente vado in ipnosi una sorta di
trance provate ad immaginare questo
scenario completamente bianco candido
che quasi magico metafisico non senti un
rumore perché sono percorsi
percorsi non battuti e poi sta nevicando
di brutto e senti soltanto il rumore
sordo del del tuo fiato e di quello dei
tuoi compagni
verso il centesimo km penso di non
farcela più penso di uscire di prendere
un treno e tornarmene a casa perché ho
anche un male bestiale al ginocchio
solo che poi succede una cosa comincia a
sentire il rumore un rumore sordo che
non è quello del della della ferraglia
un rumore come questo qua un rumore che
mi fa tira sulla testa e quello che vedo
è questa meraviglia una lo spettacolo
meraviglioso di un di un gruppo di
fenicotteri rosa in piena valle di
comacchio che sembra sembra quasi
applaudirci farci la ola mentre stiamo
arrivando bene quelle immagini ali
quell'immagine meravigliosa è stata per
me un punto di svolta
mi ha fatto scoprire tutta la meraviglia
degli anni precedenti di quando ero
bambino è cominciato e ho cominciato ad
andare in bicicletta mi ha fatto
scoprire tutta la meraviglia degli anni
negli anni a seguire la meraviglia e il
concetto su cui dobbiamo concentrarci
che cos'è la meraviglia altan in questa
tavola che mi ha donato una decina
d'anni fa secondo me non riassume
benissimo la meraviglia è un mix di
azione equilibrio e visione visione
ampia perché in bicicletta la visione è
ampia per e paesaggio e paesaggio che
stupisce e paesaggio sorprendente
qualcuno ha detto che la bicicletta è
l'unico mezzo di trasporto capace di
trasformare la fatica in paesaggio
non mi riferisco soltanto al paesaggio
rurale a quello campestre c'è una
bellezza è una meraviglia anche nel
paesaggio urbano
questa e questo è un pezzo della
tangenziale delle biciclette di bologna
e questa sarà la meraviglia dei prossimi
anni
nel senso che stupirà la gente che verrà
a bologna e stupirà chi ci andrà su
quella ciclabile e magari supererà 20
chilometri orari il traffico bloccato
sul sui viali che cos'è la meraviglia la
meraviglia e questo è la prima
sensazione di equilibrio e meraviglia è
una famiglia felice che si muove in
bicicletta e meraviglia farsi
sorprendere da un arcobaleno dopo essere
stati sorpresi da una pioggia mentre
state facendo un giro in bici in collina
e meraviglia uno scorcio di una città
anche la vostra città uno scorcio che
non avete mai mai visto perché siete
continuate a fare sempre la stessa
strada questo non è meraviglia questo e
cartesio cartesio nel 1649
scrive un libro prima di morire non
moriranno successivo che si chiama le
passioni dell'anima lui l'uomo della
razionalità scrive un libro sulle
passioni e ne individua 66 primitive da
qui farà a ridiscendere
tutte quante le altre passioni sono odio
amore gioia tristezza desiderio che per
lui anche il contrario però avversione
quindi e binari anche questa la
meraviglia non la coppia a a nient'altro
perché secondo lui non sa contrario oggi
noi sappiamo che la meraviglia al
contrario il contrario della meraviglia
e l'indifferenza bene lo spazio di
agibilità della bicicletta
si muove tra meraviglia e indifferenza
in questo
come dire il ranch patemicò c'è il
futuro della bicicletta e secondo me il
futuro il futuro il futuro delle nostre
delle nostre città quindi meraviglia
indifferenza
se vi interessa la meraviglia allora
dovete capire come si misura la
meraviglia la meraviglia si misura con
l'andatura del sorriso
se guardate le persone con cui uscite in
bici le persone che amate ma
possibilmente questa è una persona che
amo ad esempio e e poi alla fine del
giro vedete se sul loro volto c'è
stampigliato un sorriso se c'è sorriso
siete andati alla sua andatura del
sorriso che non è la vostra perché la
mia magari e sui colli e non su strade
pianeggianti per cui rispettate e
cercate l'andatura del del sorriso delle
persone per cercare di produrre ciclisti
felici
lasciatemi riassumere brevissimamente
dove la bicicletta oggi oggi la
bicicletta è a un punto di svolta dopo
tanti anni passati
sperando che potesse cambiare e le città
oggi io sono convinto che la bicicletta
sta per cambiare le città e lo sta
facendo e lo sta facendo con con la
meraviglia e con e con il sorriso
gandhi per raccontare per raccontare il
suo processo di liberazione dell'india
dall'oppressione dall'oppressione
inglese disse una volta primati
ignoreranno poi ti di leader hanno poi
ti combatteranno alla fine to vincerai
ebbene oggi io credo che stiamo per
vincere e stanno per vincere le città
ecco perché vi lascio con questo invito
prendete la vostra bicicletta inforcate
la guardate il mondo dal punto di vista
di un sellino
sono convinto che prima o poi la
meraviglia irromperà delle vostre vite e
vela cambierà per sempre grazie
vp bellini